from tracksuits that have seen better
days to slick vinyl catsuits
we're here to investigate what dc's bad
guys actually look like in the comics
they still call home
and just how different that is from what
makes it onto the silver screen
the joker has a pretty packed wardrobe
batman t-shirts
he's sporting them in sean murphy's
miniseries batman white knight
sleeveless doctor's coat joker donned
one in batman r.i.p
still over the decades a central look
emerges classic suits and tuxedos in
green
orange purple and red he first appeared
in a large bow tie purple gloves and
well pomaded hair
though artists often add a couple of
unhinged details to his look
most often must hair are outsized teeth
the joker tends to keep himself as well
turned out
as a downton abbey character modern
movie audiences have three very
different jokers to consider
heath ledger's clown is a mangy
monstrosity whose makeup visually flakes
off throughout the movie
joaquin phoenix's take on the character
looks to famous mid-century television
clowns like bozo and howdy duties
clarabelle for inspiration
jared leto's demonic wild child swaps
formal wear for
face tattoos and lyrid purple coats over
a bare chest
each of these interpretations tells the
audience something different
letos joker is more of a mafioso than a
mastermind
phoenix's joker is a 1970s man gone off
the deep end and ledger's joker is a
nightmarish vision of urban decay
but not one of them is as sharply
dressed as the madman of the monthlies
some of those movie guys are just a mess
do i really look like a guy with a plan
doomsday's appeal is pretty much
summed up by his name he is the
reckoning at the end of superman's
adventures
appropriately he is best known as the
villain of the death of superman
the result of alien scientist krypton's
genetic engineering doomsday is a grey
goliath whose skeleton spikes through
his skin
doomsday's incarnation in batman vs
superman dawn of justice was a very
different creature indeed
the product of lex luthor's meddling
with general zod's corpse
this doomsday was as large and gray as
his comic counterpart but not quite as
hard-edged
though spikes of bone emerged mid-battle
from his skin
he starts out as a deformed gray brute
moreover this doomsday developed the
ability to shoot blasts of energy
out of his hands after absorbing the
energy from a nuclear strike
the doomsday of the comics only develops
this ability after his faithful battle
with the outsiders
super team doomsday on film is a
grunting primal version of brutality
something like the distant ancestor of
the comics version
the feline fatale likes to keep it sleek
the catwoman of the 1966 batman tv
series
accentuated basic black with glittering
accessories and a striking mask
batman returns imagined catwoman as a
city girl pushed at madness
symbolized by her visibly stitched
patchwork of the catsuit
halle berry's costume was shredded but
still as dark as the shadows
the dark knight rises depicted catwoman
as a burglar in matte black
with pointed stilettos and cat-eared
tips on her goggles
these incarnations though impressive in
their cinematic vision
rely on small details to do the heavy
lifting of her characterization
but the catwoman of comics has a more
varied wardrobe
ranging from emerald evening wear to
royal purple catsuits
for all that trail of the catwoman
artist darwin cook's 2001 redesign
was so immediately iconic in it catwoman
wears a simple cat suit and a cat-eared
cowl
set off by flat-footed motorcycle boots
and flared goggles
it's simple and remarkably practical but
its sleek details make it timeless
catwoman's taste might run to the
extravagant but when she's on the job
she keeps things functional what are we
gonna do
there's not much we can do that's who i
think it is
being the literal god of war requires an
impressive outfit
aries does just that in the 2017 wonder
woman film
with shining armor spiked helmet and
enormous weaponry
war sure ain't subtle ares of the comics
follow suit
in george perez's classic tale on wonder
woman and greg ruka and nicola scott's
recent revival
he wears dark blue armor a plumed helmet
and a billowing cape it's largely the
same design
as what ended up on screen aside from
one important difference
in the early comics ares has no
discernible body
every inch of flash is covered save a
narrow gap in his helmet
on any normal human this would reveal a
portion of the nose lips and chin
on the comic character however there is
only depthless
darkness studded with two smoldering
eyes was it cool to see the man who
played mild manner remus
lupin glowing beneath the helmet yes
but it would have been equally striking
to see his face disappear
after doing away with his disguise
remember when the villain of suicide
squad
opened an apocalyptic portal through the
art of aggressive belly dancing
an enchantress's defense when you're a
millennial-spanning
interdimensional witch goddess you can
pretty much make your own rules
that certainly applied to the
character's wardrobe which shifted from
rags and tarnished jewelry
to a billowing two-piece affair crowned
by a rune inlaid headdress
was it an outfit made for serious battle
no way
but enchantress's powers allow her to do
other things
please don't touch me please don't touch
me introduced in a 1966 issue of strange
adventures as
the switcheroo whicharoo the enchantress
has cycled through many outfits
but all of them are in her signature
bright green and most feature a
flamboyant cloak
perhaps her most unique costume is her
very first a classic witch hat paired
with a harlequin patterned mini dress
not great for suicide squad but perfect
for the swinging 60s
dr poison is one of wonder woman's
earliest villains
and one of her most terrifying a
princess working as the head of the
nazis poison division
she disguises her gender under her green
doctor's gear
and a mask with a rictus grin her
greatest creation was
reverso a poison that would force allied
soldiers into doing the opposite of what
they were told
dr poison isn't a princess in disguise
as a man
or working with nazis in 2017's wonder
woman
but she is just as deadly in an
intriguing twist
dr poison's mask was re-imagined as a
series of flesh-colored plates
affixed to her face to hide the scars
exposure to her own creations rot
those plates aren't just striking but
rooted in actual history
soldiers disfigured in world war one
brought about new innovations in
prosthesis
dr poison might not have been the
leering specter of the acts as she began
as
but she filled wonder woman audiences
with a comparable sense of terror
dc's new gods exceeded conventional
notions of superheroes
they've got fabulous powers extravagant
outfits and wheeled technology capable
of transporting them across dimensions
steppenwolf is a new god and his
incarnation in the justice league lived
up to that race is larger
larger-than-life reputation
he was a cgi colossus of armor stone
and steel beneath his costume he was
oddly wax in an appearance
his skin a drained gray crisscrossed by
alien grooves
add in two bony outgrowths off his chin
and you had a truly fearsome looking
opponent
[Music]
the steppenwolf of modern comics is
similarly grand but he didn't start out
that way
he first appears in the new gods series
sporting green medieval armor
complete with a bicocket hat that makes
him look more robinhood than new god
but in modern renditions his armor is
red and black
accented by a skull worn at his waist
and
red claw-like stripes top his shoulders
in sharp contrast to the steppenwolf of
the movies however
his comic incarnation is notably
handsome he wears a dark beard sometimes
twisted into long braids
movie steppenwolf is utterly unknowable
while comic steppenwolf is a man who
dressed differently could pass for a
hero as a kid whose powers allow him to
transform into a buff
super heroic adult in a flashy red suit
shazam embodies one of the most potent
fantasies in
all of comics appropriately his
archenemy dr savannah
is boldly drawn dr savannah a criminal
mastermind whose love
of depraved science is matched only by
his ego
give me your power
or die his appearance in shazam isn't
too terribly far off the mark as in the
comics he is portrayed
as a bald smirking man who oozes ill
intentions
but unlike the villain mark strong
portrayed on screen
the dr savannah of the comics is a
hunched little man with an oversized
head
his thick glasses obscure his eyes which
paired with the old school lab cody
favors
create nothing so much as the very image
of the mad scientist
add in the diabolical alien worm mr mind
he's often seen with
and it all results in a man you'd give a
wide birth to on the street
raz al ghul didn't become the head of
the league of assassins through subtlety
he clawed his way to power over the
course of centuries
infiltrated the halls of the wealthy and
connected through genius and
determination
and sired talia al ghul herself one of
batman's most
formidable foes accordingly he cuts a
fine figure
roz adorns his roguish good looks with
emerald green capes bordered in gold
intricately wrought jewelry and often a
lush
length of fur liam neeson's portrayal in
batman begins is a dramatic departure
from this
rich refinement there roz blends
into the shadows through muted suits and
dark training gear
he is last the distant master of a
thousand deadly hands and more the hands
themselves
seeking to add bruce wayne to his ranks
through ceptifuge
you haven't beaten me you've sacrificed
your footing for a killing stroke
though his subdued aesthetic is indeed
appropriate to that approach
one can't help but miss the flamboyance
of his comic incarnation
the man who had become ocean master was
born to power
he's the type of guy who likes to refer
to his trident as a scepter
and dresses accordingly orm wears purple
scaled armor
a thinned helmet that covers his eyes
with black red oblongs
and a cape even underwater ocean
master's final costume in aquaman
is actually pretty darn close to what he
wears in the comics including the cape
but that resplendent outfit comes only
at the end of the film
during the final face-off and is
preceded by a host of other extravagant
costumes
he begins with dark armor of
considerably more bulk than the sleek
looks favored by the
other denizens of atlantis later he dons
another set of armor
wrought entirely of gold topped off by a
finned crown
orm's costumes send one very clear
message
he used to be obeyed and he wants
everyone to know it
super villain gimmicks range wildly in
fearsomeness
sometimes you get the joker essentially
the embodiment of chaos
and sometimes well we get a guy like
captain boomerang
no one is exactly surprised to see a guy
named captain boomerang in a well-worn
tracksuit
and pop collar trench coat and suicide
squad
missing a few teeth and sporting some
facial scars he's a guy who revels in
being weird and even a little
off-putting
the kind of oddball who fits in right
alongside killer croc and harley quinn
captain boomerang is just as weird in
the comics but with a good deal more
panache
rather than a ratty tracksuit he began
as a man in a boomerang pattern tunic
ascot and jaunty blue garrison cap
though recent incarnations have favored
a more toned down look
his looks remain well cut and elegant
and often still
incorporate boomerang patterns in an
ascot he might be strange
but he's gonna look good doing it even
when he's bothering his team mates with
his boorishness and hijinks
one can only imagine the horror captain
boomerang of the comics would feel upon
glimpsing his motley film
self to say nothing of the latter's
preoccupation with unicorns
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite superhero movies are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]